welcome back to cbs this morning after a
massive cbs news investigation
into the military's failure to handle
sexual assaults
the army now admits it must do better
in a video statement released last night
secretary of the army ryan mccarthy
also said the sexual assault prevention
and response program
in the army has not done its job this
morning women hired to work for the
defense department's program
are speaking out about the problems they
witnessed
cbs evening news anchor and managing
editor nora o'donnell
spoke with them as part of her exclusive
investigation
i was violently raped in my room nearly
two dozen survivors who spoke with cbs
news say the military sexual assault
program
put in place to protect them instead
failed them i was bleeding i had bruises
the proof was on my body
and yet i didn't think it was going to
be enough they described problems with
reporting their assaults
and the backlash they experienced when
they did i was being harassed so bad
by my commanders that ended up having a
nervous breakdown
they just go after you because you're
the victim and you're the problem i
cannot look
at another junior soldier sobbing
and know that they've been assaulted and
people like
oh it'll get better just go deploy
that's not okay amy braley frank
marianne bustin
and lindsey knapp were all hired by the
defense department's sexual assault
prevention and response program
to help fix the problem my greatest
concern with the program itself
is that there are some bad actors and
commanders that have found a way
to sweep these things under the rug
commanders are required to refer reports
of sexual assault to criminal
investigators
but amy found evidence commanders were
investigating some cases
themselves which violates the military's
own
code of justice i discovered written
documentation of illegal investigations
and victims languishing
and i continued to ask for help over and
over again
and to no avail the military says
there's zero tolerance when it comes to
sexual assault
is that true no i feel like the
commanders are ill-equipped
to make these decisions that's why we're
here we're the subject matter experts we
advise them but they do not listen
each day they allow these things to
occur there's no zero tolerance there's
tolerance
of sexual assault and rape absolutely
we're seeing an increase in reports
decreasing convictions and more and more
service members reporting that they're
being retaliated against
in the military's most recent anonymous
survey 64 percent of women who reported
a sexual assault
said they experienced retaliation people
are afraid
when i have young ladies and men say
the rape was bad but i don't want to go
through this other thing
because it's worse than the rape what's
worse than the rape the retaliation
the treatment the judgment amy was
suspended a year ago from her position
as a victim advocate
the day after she contacted a commanding
general about retaliation she was seeing
in the army
i think the breath and the depth of the
problem is so large
that they really don't want the general
public to understand that they don't
have it under control
marianne was fired in june after the air
force commander
she complained to about the sexually
offensive culture on base
took away her credentials they didn't
want change and they refused to do it
and they said you're going to be gone
and and they were right
that's how powerful the system is it's
it's powerful here's three
women trying to fight a male-dominated
system
where men are the ones deciding whether
women were assaulted or harassed it's a
difficult fight
and lindsay believes reporting her
concerns about the army's elite fighters
to a commanding general
led to her firing in july so it all came
to a head when i reported that
delta force was covering up rape what do
you believe they were trying to cover up
i don't think they want people to know
that their elite fighting force
is capable of doing these kinds of
things and you believe you were
retaliated against
for advocating on behalf of this rape
victim absolutely
how can this be fixed don't put us under
commanders
where if i'm going to tell you you're
violating a law and then you can just
turn around and fire me
doesn't make any sense we're not even
the sexual assault survivor we are the
victim advocate but then they see us
being retaliated against and they see us
being fired
for standing up for them i think one
thing that we've failed to mention here
is that the things that we're talking
about are crimes
for anyone to overlook that
not handle it appropriately that's a
crime in and of itself
not just the people who carried out the
assault and the rape you're talking
about the ones that
retaliated against and covered it up
absolutely
absolutely you think it's time for the
military to have a me too movement it's
time
i encourage everybody who's maybe
experienced this to report it to your
congressional leaders to the ig the
office of special counsel
flood them flood them you
matter your voice needs to be heard and
it needs to be heard now
the military declined our request for an
interview but last night the secretary
of the army ryan mccarthy
responded to our investigation this
topic has captivated the attention
of america and our army leaders
it is abundantly clear we must do better
the army promised a new action plan next
month
norah o'donnell cbs news washington
in statements the army says it
encourages program employees
experiencing retaliation
to report it the air force told us its
advocates are crucial in efforts
to combat sexual assault and their
guidance is
valued all those women very strong very
credible
and i don't understand how you can
report it to someone and the person
you're reporting it to is the one that
makes a decision about whether it moves
forward or not
that just doesn't make any sense i agree
bravo to
nora bravo to the investigation scheme
for the army to come out and say it's
abundantly clear we need to do better
that's only because these stories exist
so well done this has been an incredibly
comprehensive investigation but
over a year yeah because in the
beginning they weren't saying anything
on the record so to have the army
secretary
to go on the on the air and say that
very very powerful
certainly more is coming out of this
story i'm convinced of that